gas prices being so high right now we
know it impacts all of our viewers us so
we have started a campaign with conoco
to help gift you a good day let's take a
look at how i surprised one lucky conoco
customer and gifted her a good day
i met erica at the conoco on east
centennial she shares her car with her
sister we always can switch in between
who's paying for gas at the moment i
can't afford the five dollar gaff to
afford gas on top of caring for her five
dogs she has to prioritize what she
spends her cash on gas is now something
i'm budgeting more for than i thought it
would ever have to instead of just being
like oh hey i need gas well no i need to
think about what i need to buy how am i
going to eat how am i going to pay my
bills it's a it's a big sacrifice right
now to put gas in your car yeah it is
then it was time to gift erica a good
day i tell you what what if we told you
that we were going to help you out with
your gas today that would be amazing
honestly eight news now and conoco gas
is gonna gift you a good day and buy
your tank of gas today thank you so much
i'm excited
will that help you out yes i definitely
will thank you so much oh you're so
welcome yeah if it helps you out yes it
really will yes especially with all the
extra driving we're doing we're happy
for you thank you so much
congratulations thank you thank you
erica was really really sweet and really
grateful i had a great time surprising
her and you never know you could be next
so we're always on the lookout for
somebody to help fill up their tank yeah
that's fun it is fun and how were the
dogs oh the dogs were adorable